This episode is brought to you by Ridge wallet.
Hey wisecrack, Jared here,
you artists have had as big an impact on our image of the apocalypse as
Australian director and actually fully trained medical Dr. George Miller
Miller's vision of a leather clad post-apocalyptic wasteland has captured our
collective imagination since the release of mad max, the road warrior in 1981.
And while we mostly tend to think of mad, max,
is that franchise with more violent car crashes than lines of dialogue.
These films hold our attention because they, and indeed most of Miller's work,
explore big questions around life, death, and power who owns the body.
And what is it for who gets to decide who lives and who dies and how can we live
full lives? When death is all around us today,
we're going to explore George Miller's answers to these questions and more.
So go get some spray paint,
flood your car with gasoline and witness us as we dive straight into this
wisecrack edition on the politics of life and death in Madmax and Bay
and spoils ahead for grown men getting straight up horny over cars.
And again also, babe.
But before we continue, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor Ridge wallet,
the Ridge wallet is a light sleek and industrial wallet designed to last you a
lifetime. Each wallet is made with RFID blocking technology,
which protects you from digital pickpockets.
The durable metal also means each wallet comes with a lifetime warranty.
So this could be the last wallet you ever buy. It's perfect.
If you don't want to carry around a bulky old other lump in your pocket,
but still want to maximize the amount of cards you carry.
It holds up to 12 cards and still has room for cash.
I got the titanium gunmetal wallet and nothing beats how sleek it is.
The Ridge team is so confident that you'll like it.
That if you don't and send it back within 45 days,
you will receive a full refund. If you're not in need of a wallet,
it's the perfect gift for father's day, which is right around the corner.
Grab your own Ridge wallet today by going to
ridge.com/wisecrack and use the promo code wise crack to get 10% off,
you'll get free worldwide shipping and returns.
So click the link in the description to get one today. And now back to the show.
First, a little scene setting.
George Miller's mad max universe opens in a near future Australia where
ultraviolet motorcycle gangs,
Duke it out with ultra violent cops for control of the roads.
Protagonist max rocket Tansky's family is murdered in the first film and the
series follows him as he wanders the wasteland in the wake of a nuclear
pocalypse, struggling to survive turf Wars between rival group,
while holding onto some shred of his sanity,
to understand a lot of what Miller does in these movies.
We can turn to our old friend and war boy, caus player philosopher, Michel Fuko,
Fuko spent much of his career crafting and refining a concept.
He called biopower in a nutshell,
the idea that power in all its forms has increasingly come to bear on life and
biological function.
Biopower according to Fuko involves the calculated management of life,
the subjugation of bodies and the control of populations and distributing the
living in the domain value and utility in short modern power.
Isn't just about the exercise of force, but building and managing a population.
This management plays a big role in the politics of the wasteland.
Mad max beyond Thunderdome, for instance,
revolves around the fight between auntie entity and masterblaster for control of
barter town, a settlement that literally runs on biological activity.
Specifically the methane produced from pigs and relies on prison,
labor to process set feces and in mad max fury road and Wharton Joe uses the
tried and true biopolitical technology of chastity belts to control his wives,
reproductive capacity and hoarded for himself.
But the concept of biopower can only take us so far in our analysis of Miller's
work to go deeper.
We have to move past the politics of life and explore the politics of death in
his 2003 essay, Negro politics, Cameroonian philosopher, and political theorist,
a shield in Bemba formulated the idea of Niekro power as an update to
[inaudible] concept of biopower. According to members,
much of the world now runs on political machinery that is designed not to
protect and control life, but to produce death in vast quantities,
as he explains it,
Negro politics involves the generalized instrumentalization of human existence.
It brings about the creation of death, worlds,
new and unique forms of social existence in which people take on the status of
living dead. Obviously even Bemba isn't writing some walking dead fan fiction.
Rather. He means that in a jurisdiction permeated by Negro politics,
such as a slave powered plantation or an area subject to colonial rule members
of certain groups are allowed to live so long as they are useful,
but denied status as fully sentient human beings with their own rights and
subjectivity.
These people are physically or psychologically named to Mark them as lesser than
in this way. They are kept in what new Ben Beck refers to as a state of injury.
This state of injury is rampant in the world of Madmax.
These movies love to explore the weird and terrifying ways that near future
Australians degrade each other into mere objects in the road warrior a gang
straps,
prisoners to the front of their cars to be used as living hood ornaments,
moreover gang boss, Lord humongous,
arguably even puts his own fighters into a state of injury by classifying them,
not as people, but this animals
[inaudible] and in fury road,
people are reduced to all kinds of weird objects meant to serve a Morton Joe's
needs.
Max is kidnapped and turned into a blood bag and Morton Joe keeps a collection
of lactating women hooked up to an industrial pumping machine to produce
mother's milk. And then of course there are Morton Joe's wives,
or as they're known around the Citadel Britas.
He's priced breeders in a Morton shows eyes, these women.
Our property instrumentalized in,
in bemba's terms to the point where he keeps them behind a literal bank vault
door,
as if they were a stash of gold bars or the last remaining copy of final fantasy
seven,
he values their lives only in so far as they can make his babies against this
Negro political backdrop where a human life is presumed to be a resource.
Rather, an end in itself,
Ben Beck claims that people tend to use one of two basic strategies to find
meaning and make life bearable.
The first and most obvious is the logic of survival.
The approach to life that finds satisfaction in being the last person standing
max embodies this logic throughout the series and explicitly voices it in the
opening shot of fury road.
A mountain root juice to a single instinct.
So five.
More complex is the logic of martyrdom. The way of thinking that drives suicide,
bombers, kamikaze pilots,
and so on to kill large numbers of people by killing themselves.
According to him, Ben Bev, when the logic of martyrdom is in full swing,
the besieged body becomes a piece of metal whose function is to sacrifice,
to bring eternal life into being this logic finds its fullest expression in the
cult of the V8,
the religion that encourages the war boys to win eternal life by dying in
service to a Morton Joe knucks,
for instance deals with his hellish life and impending death by cancer,
who fantasizing about the opportunity to die a glorious death.
If I'm going to die, I'm gonna die historic on the fury road.
More than anything else.
The dying knucks desires eternity in the form of Valhalla.
I die. I'll never forget.
When he fails to kill Furiosa.
He frames that failure as the loss of his one chance at eternal life.
I should be walking with you and mortar visiting with the arrows a full time.
And speaking of McFees thing broke to be a big fat pig.
So far we've been discussing how George Miller explores questions around life,
death, sovereignty, and so on through Madmax. But George Miller,
isn't just a former medical doctor who directed the mad max series.
The route his career Miller has been involved in a variety of genres among them,
dark fantasy medical drama and children's films,
including believe it or not fave and happy feet weirder still throughout
all of these movies, bio politics and Negro politics still loom large,
not convinced allow us to re-introduce to you.
What is arguably the most sexual of penguin base children's movies.
Some might say too sexual.
I will retire now to my coach of perpetual indulgence.
Ladies whose first happy feet.
Follows the adventures of a mumble,
a penguin born in the midst of a fish shortage to a society organized around the
act of singing.
When his father Memphis realizes that mumble wants to dance rather than saying
his deeply.
I thought it was kind of cute, but it just ain't penguin. Okay.
Emperor land fetishize is singing and identifies it as the only legitimate way
to find a mate.
This behavior lines up neatly with Bukos description of the so-called science of
sex that developed in conjunction with biopower. For instance,
he notes how the strange pleasures of individuals were long considered harmful
to all important population health in contrast, proper normal sex,
allegedly ensured a physically vigorous population. In other words,
getting down in a non-traditional way,
came to be seen as literally dangerous to the health and safety of your
neighbor, your country, et cetera.
It's on these grounds that the community elders attack, mumbles tap dancing.
It's just this kind of backsliding. This has brought the scarcity up on us.
The emperor penguins, biopolitical logic,
the only safe and healthy way to channel sexual energy is through singing.
Anything else is seen as a direct threat to the wellbeing of the group.
Biopower plays a similar role in Miller's the witches of Eastwick the entire
plot of this dark comedy revolves around a sexual relationship between the devil
and three women who unknowingly summoned him to their conservative new England
town. The townsfolk condemned their behavior as not just immoral but dangerous.
Yeah. Oh, that is everybody.
Morton.
Joe Jack Nicholson's devil ultimately seeks to use the women in his life as
vessels for his offspring of fact recognized only by the hilariously unhinged
about churchgoer Felicia who slowly loses her mind, imagining the sinful stupid.
He'll probably get,
he will increase this number.
Miller's non Madmax projects.
Also engage heavily with Niekro power by exploring questions around who lives
and who dies and why nominal kids movie,
babe explores the state of injury through the lens of life on a farm from the
get-go.
The actually horrifying film makes it clear that the farm animals lives depend
on their ability to provide utility to the Huggins.
Or as member might say their lives depend on how they can instrumentalize
themselves if they can't do that while alive. Well,
there's always dinner to think about like the population of the Citadel.
The animals are grouped into a rough cast system based on the role they play on
the farm. The exact mechanics of this divide are spelled out by Ferdinand,
a duck who tries to steal the morning crowing responsibilities in order to
become indispensable to the house.
Humans don't eat cats. Why indispensable?
They catch mice humans don't eat boosters.
Why they make eggs with the hand to wake everyone up in the morning,
animals lower in the hierarchy.
Are kept in a state of injury where they are reduced to the food items that they
are destined to become.
You are.
The tragedy of the Negro political arrangement is that it gives the half lives,
pork chops and blood bags of the world. Only one way to experience something,
approaching personhood to deal out death and violence themselves at this point
is subtler in babe than in Madmax.
The pig only gets as far as biting a sheep on the leg, but we can dream can't.
We, when Ben Beck claims that under Negro politics,
a person becomes a subject that is a fully individually to human being in the
struggle and the work for which he or she confronts death and upholding the work
of death. In other words,
the extent to which you are allowed to be a unique person is determined by how
much killing you can do. If you're a victim,
you don't matter throughout the mad max franchise.
The right to define oneself is limited mainly to men and occasional woman who
have the power and the will to subject others, to violence and death.
Employing flamboyant costumes and monologues characters distinguish themselves
from the draft multitudes by killing effectively and with a particular sense of
style.
As a member out murder in a Negro political environment tends to become over the
top, even perversely playful in the wasteland,
it helps to be a bit of a ham toe cutter and his gang in particular,
the ill-fated Nightrider demonstrate the link between killing and personhood
using violence and chaos as opportunities for [inaudible].
Uh, no, not right.
I'm a fuel injected suicide machine.
The speeches and Cod pieces get bigger in the road warrior with humongous
employing what appears to be a full-time hype.
No worries.
And the trend continues through fury road with next feeling most like a person
when attempting a suicide run on the war room.
I don't know that.
Not to be outdone.
The bullet farmer responds to the loss of his eye with a speedy personal
reasons.
Just that.
Strikingly max actually avoids defining himself in terms of his violent deeds.
What do I call you? Does it matter?
Max,
in other words has been so warped by his time in the wasteland and by the logic
of survival that he doesn't even want an identity to take a name after all is to
make a kind of stand a liability for a person who just wants to drive away from
trouble as far and as fast as he can. And yet,
for a guy who makes movies about sexual assault, suicide bombings,
and horny penguins,
George Miller injects his stories with a surprising amount of hope,
hot up in cruel biopolitical and Negro political systems.
His protagonists ultimately find ways to transcend those systems and live in
ways that leave the world better than they found it. In other words,
they find the redemption that max and Furiosa are looking for and in the process
becomes subjects without resorting to pointless killing just before the world
goes completely to a pre wasteland. Max expresses his fear of losing himself.
Should he spend too much time on the.
I'm scared? You know why
I'm beginning to enjoy water spotty week, any longer out on that road.
And I'm one of them, you know, the terminal crazy.
Which of course is exactly what happens. Max loses his family,
takes revenge on tow cutters gang and begins his dissent to the condition.
We find him in at the beginning of furious.
Road, root juice to a single instinct.
So five.
Beginning with the road warrior Miller challenges us to imagine a way back for
max. That is a way for him to live again.
A man haunted by the DV,
a man had wandered out into the wasteland.
The way to live. Again.
It turns out to fight back against the logics of Negro politics,
namely survival and martyrdom to take actions that put one's own life at risk
and have some greater purpose beyond taking as many possible people with you.
When you die.
Bade finds out how to live in a Negro political environment by learning to herd
sheep with kindness rather than cruelty after his one attempt at being an to the
sheep, fails to get him any results.
Bade commits to simply asking them nicely to move.
No need for all this Wolf nonsense. Yulman all a nice little pig.
Like you need do his.
With this radical new approach. Bade creates for himself,
a form of subjectivity, not bound to the cycle of dominance,
which fly describes earlier in the film. He is neither a pork chop nor a Wolf.
As the terrified sheep called the violent dogs. He is the sheep pig.
This dynamic of taking a riskier,
less efficient action for the benefit of friends,
rather than the destruction of enemies is also key to the redemption in fury
road. In his final moments,
knucks transcends the normal logic of martyrdom by turning his body into a
shield that saves his friends rather than a weapon to be used against his
enemies. He gives us life, not out of hatred for the other,
but out of love for the first people in his life.
Who've recognized him as anything more than a fanatical soldier.
As he crashes the rig,
blocking the past and allowing the others time to escape his new friends,
become the first people to truly honor his request,
to witness him driving away and gracing him with the same hand sign to Buddha.
Leni used to honor their dead. They recognize him as the full person.
He could never become as long as he worshiped in Morton. Jo. Similarly,
max becomes a subject by transcending the logic of survival rather than taking
the motorcycle offered to him and driving far, far away,
he can Cox a wild plan to drive straight back the way they came through in
Morton Joe's forces to take the Citadel for themselves. In other words,
max risks,
his own life for the chance to create a better life for the people he's come to
care about.
This allows him to become a subject outside of the Negro political framework to
reclaim his.
Name. My name is max.
Now none of these endings are quite that simple. At the end of the day.
Baby is still an unpaid farm labor who could be turned into spare ribs.
The moment he stops being useful and Furiosa and company find themselves in
control of a massive war machine.
It'll take a lot of work to deprogram a Citadel full of war pups,
but at a minimum Miller offers us hope that in a world too often,
colluded by coercion and violence,
we can find a way to be something other than victims or perpetrators as Max's
one-time commanding officer puts it.
Oh. Then you won't be Mac
give a bad day.
Babe.
Max Furiosa and Knox all proved themselves to be bigger than the labels put on
them by the Negro political power structure. Babe is a sheep pig,
not a pork chop. Furiosa is a freedom fighter, not an imperator.
Knucks is a Loverboy, not a war boy.
And max is more than a man reduced to a single instinct.
He's a human and as hard as that can be sometimes. So are we,
but what do you think wisecrack?
Where can you see biopower and Negro power at work in our world today?
What are some of your favorite stories that grapple with these and similar
themes?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure to subscribe and ring that bell
big, thanks to our dope patrons for supporting the channel and our podcasts stay
shiny, stay Chrome, and as always peace.
[Inaudible].